when thinking about beautiful typography
what is your favorite letter number or
symbol
i know i know ridiculous question but
let is there
you there
or
look at the last page
at the very end of the index
what is that
there's a book by dr seuss called on
beyond zebra and he gave a name to that
did you say dr seuss gave a name to that
dr seuss this is a uh
s-e-u-s-s he he wrote children's books
in the 50s
40s and 50s
what are you talking about cat in the
hat doctor
yeah
that's it
yeah on on beyond zebra did it did yeah
did it get to
soviet union
[Laughter]
yeah doctors no we did
dr seuss did not come to the soviet
union but
since you oh actually i think he did
actually a little bit when we were
um
that that was a uh
book
his maybe cat in the hat or
or green eggs and ham i think was used
to learn english oh okay so i think it
made it in that way
okay i i didn't like those as much
as bartholomew cubbins but but i used to
know
bartholomew covens by heart when i was
young
so what the heck is the symbol we're
looking at
there's so much going on he has a name
for it at the end of his book on beyond
zebra
who made it
he did he did
so there's
it looks like a bunch of vines
uh well is that symbol of existence
by the way he
he made a movie in the early 50s
i don't remember the name of the movie
now you can probably find it on easily
enough but
it it features uh
dozens and dozens of pianos all playing
together at the same time and
but but that all the scenery is sort of
[Music]
based on the kind of artwork that was in
his books and uh
the fantasy big
you know
based of seuss land or so
and i saw the movie only once or twice
but it's
but it's quite
i'd like to see it again
that's that's really fascinating that
you gave him
they gave him shout outs here
you